we're joined by the housing and
community secretary robert generic thank
you very much for being on the programme
i'm not sure if you managed to hear
everything that general jonathan
reynolds was
saying there he says that their murky
allegations about this
uh allocation of funding from a scheme
mundo by your department
the town's fund dishing out money to 101
deprived areas but
newark and your constituency was chosen
even though it ranked as a 270th most
deprived area
in the country what's going on
well sophie we're in the middle of a
national crisis and all the labour party
could do
is make up political points touring
stories which are completely baseless
my department's officials have been very
clear that we chose the towns
for our 3.6 billion towns fund on a
robust and fair methodology that's there
for
for everybody to see we're not going to
apologize for investing in communities
that were left behind and undervalued by
the labour party
for many many years many of those were
won by the conservative party at the
last general election
but that's a reflection on the labour
party not upon the methodology by which
we chose
those towns we're going to keep on
supporting those communities that's
absolutely at the heart of the mission
of this government
you talk about the methodology but you
can understand why it does seem a little
bit strange you know these
towns were chosen just before the
election 61 of the towns selected by you
to receive money were conservative
targets even though
other areas were ranked as more deprived
by civil servants so
was taxpayers money used to try and win
that that's not with respect with
respect sophie that's not actually
correct the
methodology was created long before the
general election uh it actually was
created by the previous
administration uh before boris johnson
became prime minister
we chose the top 40 members in many ways
conservative targets
and well actually many of them were not
conservative targets it's
the fact that many of those 61 were won
by the conservatives at the election
well i think that's lost by 145
to the labour party than it is on the
conservative party's policies
but we had a fair and robust methodology
it was decided
by ministers and by civil servants and
it's been set out at great length by
the department uh i think the labour
party here is really trying to distract
from the fact
that they don't like us to be making
good on our promise
to support these communities to give
them the investment that they need in
infrastructure in skills
in technology and in culture and that
investment
designed long before the pandemic is
even more important today
because we want to help these
communities to grow and to recover
from the very challenging economic
circumstances that many of them are
facing at the moment
so just just to be crystal clear did you
select newark in your constituency to
receive the money and if you didn't
know no no sophie would have been
extremely clear
ministers don't make decisions about
their own constituencies that's
a long-standing uh position they're done
by other ministers in the department
okay okay and thank you uh for that just
finally on that
are you going to go to parliament to
explain yourself as labour want
we're not going to get involved in party
political point scoring i'm afraid this
is just a distraction tactic
by the labour party we've answered all
the questions and happy to to answer any
more that might arise but there really
is nothing to see here
okay now i'm keen to talk to you about
uh kovid about the government's response
to
uh coronavirus obvious obviously so many
of our viewers will be very nervous
ahead of what we're expecting to hear
from the prime minister tomorrow
there's been an awful lot briefing about
a new three-tier system where
if you're on the highest tier uh the
highest number of infections then
you'll be under stricter restrictions
than elsewhere
what should we expect to hear tomorrow
well the prime minister's going to make
an announcement tomorrow so i don't want
to preempt what he
intends to say but in addition to the
basic
simple rules that apply to the whole
country we're
designing a framework for those places
for where the virus is
very strong and there will be some
rules which apply consistently but then
also
we're in a very productive conversations
with local leaders
local directors of public health to ask
them if there are any further measures
that they would support which will help
to control the virus in their local
communities
so we want the strongest possible
working relationship now
between central government and local
government because the virus although
it's spreading concerningly across the
whole of
the uk it is very concentrated in some
places and so it's right that we take
action
in those communities and design the
measures
in conjunction with people who know
those places best you say the about the
importance of rules being applied
consistently
consistently so on what basis will areas
move between
different levels will it be based on
case numbers the r rate hospital
emissions
will there be a publicly available
system
well i think you'll have to wait to see
what the prime minister says on that
regard but
we've taken into account historically a
range of different factors
the number of cases per hundred thousand
is significant but there are also other
important factors
uh which we can we can use as well
including hospitalizations
and the nature of those cases whether uh
they are across the whole of the
community
or whether they're more contained in
particular settings
and what exactly should people expect if
they are in
the highest tier could there be a ban on
mixing
with other households even outside
well i can't say that today because you
have to wait for tomorrow
what we have said is that accompanying
those measures
will be a very comprehensive package of
support the chancellor has already set
out
the support for people where business is
asked to close as a result of these
additional measures that the government
will step in and pay two-thirds
of their wages he's also been clear that
those businesses will be able to apply
for grants of up to three thousand
pounds to help them cover their rent and
other expenses in addition to the
measures that he's already put in place
like
the vat cup for hospitality the business
rates holiday
uh for retail and hospitality and in
addition businesses
should be expecting what businesses
should be expecting to be ordered
to close pubs restaurants
well i'm not going to say that sophie
because you'll have to wait for tomorrow
it wouldn't be right for me to announce
on
the program what the prime minister will
say to parliament you say you see
you say with respect you say it wouldn't
be right for you to say that but
we've been given briefings for a long
time in the newspapers
every time you pick up the press you can
see more leaks local leaders are saying
that they're finding out
what's going on by reading these leaks i
mean we're not stupid they're obviously
coming from
government tens of millions of people
will be feeling that you know
sick fear of uncertainty not sure what's
coming you've got an
opportunity here to give people the
clarity that they need that businesses
need
and you're just ducking the questions
no that's not right the the prime
minister is going to set out
the way forward in the house of commons
that is the right way
to proceed the chancellor has already
set out very clearly
the very strong financial support that
we're putting in place
i appreciate that people working in
certain sectors and business owners
will be feeling very concerned but he
set out i think a fair and generous
package
to help to support them and we've spent
the weekend working with those local
leaders it was not correct what you
heard from
jonathan reynolds that hasn't been good
communication i've spent the whole
weekend talking to leaders
from merseyside from greater manchester
from other parts of the country
we're trying to work very closely with
mayors with council leaders
and chief executives to design these
measures with them that does take time
that's because we want to have good
communication between national
and local government before we announce
how we're going to take this forwards
you've been talking about the measures
put in place by the chancellor the
announcement that
the government will step in to pay
two-thirds of people's wages if
businesses are ordered to close
will there be any further financial
support for
areas uh under these postcode lockdowns
well i think that is a very significant
intervention it's building on the
winter economy plan that the chancellor
had set out two weeks ago that was very
well received it was supported
by the tuc and the cbi as you say it
ensures that those workers in businesses
that are asked to close
by law are then able to receive
two-thirds of their unearned
wages we're also providing those
business grants to the small and
medium-sized businesses
that will need them this comes on top of
the other measures many of those workers
will have been on the furlough scheme
beforehand and the latest measures we're
introducing do compare favorably
internationally it's broadly the same as
what's happening in france
and spain more generous than what's
happening in italy and germany
so i think this is specifically about
whether there'll be any more
financial support or is that it
well we can't do everything you know we
are in a deep recession
the national debt is rising i think most
reasonable people
would see the chancellor's put in place
an unprecedented package of support
this is a good safety net for those
individuals but we understand
that it will be very difficult for them
the winter is going to be
a very challenging one we can't promise
to protect every
job or every business we can promise to
offer
hope and opportunity to those
individuals who want to or will need to
look
for new jobs and opportunities that's
why the chancellor is also investing
more money in training
in dwp for work coaches in
apprenticeships why the prime minister
has now made
his lifetime skills guaranteed that
enables people of all ages
to access a good quality technical
education of the young people who are
being particularly hard
hit we're also of course launching the
kickstart program which is
going to support hundreds of thousands
of people i hope across the country to
get that first
job and get going again despite the
economic circumstances
we find ourselves in you've spoken a lot
about working with
local leaders in the sunday times today
it's saying that mayors will be given
more control
over test and trace in their local areas
that local volunteers will be able to
knock on people's doors and
tell them that they need to self-isolate
is that correct
yeah we want to work very closely with
the local mayors and with the councils
we have been since the start of the
pandemic i said this local government
secretary have been
speaking to them almost every week we're
going to be ensuring that the national
testing infrastructure
which has now increased enormously from
2000
tests today back in march to 310 000
most recently and is continuing to rise
works
in harmony with what's happening locally
because local councils
and local communities are very good at
contact tracing understandably because
they know their communities
they can mobilize council officers
particularly for harder to reach
communities we've seen that
in a number of places recently
particularly leicester where they did a
great job
and so we're going to be helping the
local councils to complement the
national
tracing infrastructure and also to have
a greater say
in track and trace as well talking about
test and trace
we currently spend more on test and
trace than we do in nurseries
and universities but the latest stats
show that the system is still
only contacting 69 of people
identified i mean is this strategy
really working
well as i say it has moved forward
enormously
over the course of the summer from a
very low base back in march now to where
we are with 310
000 tests a day we've contacted i think
over 700
000 people and helped them to
self-isolate protect
themselves and others from the virus so
it isn't
it is a constantly evolving and
improving infrastructure what we're
doing now as i say is also
bringing in the the local level as well
so we can use
all the resources of local councils
effectively as weather as well as other
resources we've offered for example
the armed forces to communities like
merseyside
and greater manchester and they can play
a role in doing this
our testing infrastructure is improving
but it does
compare favorably with other countries
we're now testing about the same if not
more
than most other developed countries
we're bringing more people
into the system we're opening up new
labs all the time and of course we'll
keep on
uh ramping up that infrastructure over
the course of the autumn and the winter
it's difficult to kind of escape the
view that as infections continue to rise
as people like jonathan van tam said
that we're at a tipping point
that the system is effectively being
overwhelmed
and you know the government's strategy
has been what boris johnson turned
whack-a-mole to
target with these local lockdowns areas
where the virus is
flaring up but with so many people tens
of millions of people
under these local lockdowns it's hard to
see that they're local anymore and we
know the moles now winning
well although the number of cases rising
rapidly across the country
there are still huge variations you know
if you go to north norfolk i think
the latest statistics showed that the
number of cases is around 19.
if you go to manchester it's well over
500.
so it is right that we pursue a
localized approach that must be
the way forward because none of us want
to see a return to blanket national
measures that would be the alternative
and that's not one that we want that
localized when one and three of us are
under national lockdown though does it
well as i say there isn't an alternative
to doing that because you don't want to
see
blanket measures across the country we
want to stick to the simple rules
elsewhere like washing your hands
uh wearing a mask staying apart on the
rule of six and have more localized
targeted measures in the places that
really need them
what we're doing now is going further
and offering local communities
their local leadership the opportunity
to come forward further with further
measures that they think will be
particularly
effective in those places and that's the
kind
of conversations we've been having over
the course of this weekend
okay now if you look at the places that
have seen these
big increases in the virus an awful lot
of them
are places where there are two
universities a big student populations
thinking places like nottingham
liverpool manchester when we look back
uh on the handling of the crisis with
hindsight
was it a big mistake to allow university
students to return
no the prime minister chose to
prioritize education
and employment wherever we can i think
that was the right choice you know these
are difficult judgments
but it's a valid judgment that it was
right to help young people to get back
into
face-to-face full-time education
wherever possible the return of schools
was the right thing to do 99 percent of
schools
are open and i think getting young
people back to university was also
the right decision universities have put
in place measures
uh whether that's trying to shield count
campuses where possible
using bubbles uh substituting
face-to-face education where they have
to
uh with remote learning so they have
used the measures that are available to
them
but you know there are no easy choices
here and we made a balanced judgment
that it was right to get people back
into education
rather than allowing the life chances
and opportunities of young people
to be put on hold any longer
and just finally um after the interview
i'm going to show a film
that i made this week i go to colchester
united football club league two club
like many really struggling to stay
afloat without the money they get from
live fans
going there why is it safe for people to
go to the pub
go to the cinema but not at socially
distance
outside football games
well you know these are difficult
choices and there are trade-offs with
each decision that we make
but the culture secretary oliver dowden
has been working extremely closely
with the football league and the
premiership to work through
uh the way in which we could safely get
fans back to watching sport we would all
love
to see that and if we can we will do
but we've got to make difficult choices
at the moment and we've chosen to
prioritize
education and employment and things like
that so
we will keep on making those difficult
decisions as far as we can but
the cultural sector is working very
closely with the sports sector
okay robert jamrick thank you very much
for being on the program today thank you